en estos momentos en las condiciones que
se encuentra la región Cuáles son las
amenazas sanitarias más apremiantes
bueno pasado en la fase más aguda
posterior al terremoto en donde el la
prioridad fundamental es rescatar con
vida a personas que estén sepultados y
que está terminándose ya
Desafortunadamente
la clave es atender adecuadamente las
necesidades que se generan y en estos
momentos con la devastación que ha
habido con la inclemencia del clima los
y con la disrupción de las operaciones
básicas de la vida Los los retos
fundamentales es que puedan surgir
enfermedades de origen
hídrico por contaminación de agua con
con contaminación fecal y infecciones
respiratorias agudas por bajas
temperaturas en situaciones simplemente
por supuesto el tema de la Salud Mental
es también otro problema como señalaba
el director de la OMS por el impacto tan
Severo que tiene un terremoto de esta
naturaleza
bueno en terreno son muchos los
suministros que faltan Qué es lo más
urgente enviar y lo más urgente a
atender
mire en todos los desastres naturales
como este
se tiende a pensar que lo que hay que
hacer es volcar una gran cantidad de
envíos y no siempre esto es la mejor de
las aproximaciones se necesitan muchos
suministros para atender los problemas
de salud los problemas de agua potable
los problemas ciertamente de falta de
techo y protección de las personas pero
no necesariamente grandes toneladas de
ropa o de medicamentos caducados muchas
veces hay que hacer un filtrado
importante de las donaciones y esto
puede llevarnos a perder tiempo y a no
tener los recursos necesarios para mover
lo que No necesariamente es un
suministro vital o esencial para una
respuesta de esta naturaleza bueno y
pasan las horas y el número de rescates
disminuye cómo hace el cuerpo para
resistir pasadas 100 120 horas bajo los
escombros y que cuidados es necesario
con estas personas en un ámbito en el
que pues repetimos faltan algunos
suministros y sobre todo falta personal
Sí el primer desafío es poder encontrar
a la gente que está sepultada bajo los
escombros lo segundo es que se trata de
personas que tienen politraumatismos
muchas veces con fracturas con con un
con una compactación de vísceras que
requieren una atención especializada y
esto Pues nos lleva a situaciones en
donde las unidades de cuidados
intensivos para una devastación de esta
naturaleza No son suficientes
se necesitan equipos médicos de
emergencia y se están enviando por parte
de muchos países para poder atender no
solo las necesidades críticas de Quienes
fueron sepultados bajo los escombros y
han sobrevivido sino también para
atender a las personas que quieran
desatendidas especialmente las personas
mayores los niños y las personas que
tienen enfermedades crónicas pueden
sufrir un serio problema de desatención
cuando los servicios de salud se han
quedado devastados cuando el personal
está diezmado y cuando es insuficiente
la capacidad local para atender los
problemas que se generan a consecuencia
del terremoto